[Music]
let's go to diane and des moines what's
up diane how are you doing
i'm doing fine how are you good good
good what's up
well i just found out that my daughter
is stripping and i don't know what to do
i want to go in with guns a blazing but
i feel like i will push her away and
this is a total 180 from what she was a
year ago and i'm just worried
something's going on
um yes something is going on what do you
think is going on
uh
well she's
trying to make ends meet she she was
living with her boyfriend
that she'd had for five or six years and
um
he was basically
just living in the house and using her
vehicle and so she decided that was
enough and she kicked him out well then
she needed to find some
way to either get a roommate or
make ends meet and so she stopped and
picked up a waitressing job at a nice
restaurant and she was starting to make
some money
she did have a girlfriend that i thought
she was
i had never never met
and i just found out that she
has been doing this before my daughter
started so i think something
uh the influence is is pulling my
daughter away from what i've taught her
too i think she just looked at she she
needed them got desperate
and needed the money um what what is
your relationship like with her
very close um just recently
um
she's kind of been pulling away um we
have opposite schedules since she's
working more evenings i'm
home in the evenings and and i work
during the day so are you on the same
town
close close
this is going to sound different than
the answer i would normally give um
but i'd go get my kid
um i would probably
um
like i i talk tough a lot about um not
letting your kids leech off of you i
talk tough about
um you know like when your kids 23 24 25
they need to have their own place they
need to go doing go do some stuff
um
this is a critical juncture
um
there's the stripping yes but there's
also the environment and then there's
the secondary trauma and then there's
the
the
primary trauma
and the path here
stripping is included in the path here
which is one of
um
so it's just gonna be tough
like i'm just looking down the barrel of
what next year in the year after that
looks like
and this is one of those moments when i
would
ask my child to come to breakfast with
me
and i would say come home
you can live here for a year to get your
feet underneath you don't have to do
this
anymore i'll take care of your bills i'm
gonna help you get a job i'm gonna help
you find some stuff come home
and she's gonna be taking some um
she's getting her master's hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on
you're missing the point
listen she just has
so and i want her to come home i don't
think she'll want to come home okay um
here's what i want though
i want her to know mom fought for her
right
and mom didn't just call because our
schedules were just all screwed up for
screw my schedule i'm going to get my
baby girl you know what i mean
yeah and here's where it's going to be
devastating for you um potentially
because it's a risk you're going all in
yeah and if she does come home house is
going to be a chaotic mess and you know
that because y'all probably fight and
don't get along
and you'll have different values and
different things it's going to be a mess
but your baby girl will be safe at least
for a season
and
you can go out there and pour your heart
out and she can say no mom i'm just
making a thousand dollars a night i'm
not coming home
and then you're gonna make a long drive
back with nobody else in that car and
it's gonna be heartbreaking and
devastating your little girl's worth a
potential heartbreak
am i right yeah yeah
so much
she's just got so much love in her heart
she does she does she has the heart of
gold and
i think she's going to have so much
trauma and regret
and shame and
okay but listen she doesn't need any of
that from you right now
no what she needs is her mama
yeah she doesn't need any of that do you
know what's gonna happen and you're
gonna start using drugs and you're gonna
have mental health challenges and all
these men are gonna she doesn't need
that she knows that
she knows right
what she needs is somebody to say i love
you come home
right and she may not come
but in two years in three years
when the bottom falls out
when things start getting jagged on the
side
she'll say i i know of a place
is dad still in the picture
um he's we're divorced we've been
divorced for five years and um
and his comment was
her friend does it i don't want her to
do it
but with the political things going on
right now people are doing things that
they don't normally
consider doing that's that's such a
stupid cop-out that guy needs to suck it
up and get off his butt and go get his
daughter what kind of stupid thing is
that to say
on the political stuff i don't care
what's going on
i know
good grief and here's the other thing i
have to be honest about this
conversation it would be disingenuous
for me not to say you may sit down with
your daughter who's getting what's your
what's her master's degree going to be
in
social work okay she may be
um
going to graduate
and
this is a six month
and she'll look up in five years and
have a great job as a social worker be
like yeah dude i just had to make ends
meet it's just kind of part of the deal
and moving on i've met those folks
okay yeah not bad people
good people found himself in a tough
patch and made decisions that i don't
think are good decisions i don't think
they're not they're good or they're not
healthy they're not good for you right
right nobody goes into that into a strip
club the whole thing the exchange the
human it's a copy of a copy of what it's
supposed to be it's fake intimacy right
yeah nobody wins in that exchange it's
just sad it breaks my heart
it does because it takes something so
right and just says here's wallpaper and
duct tape and we can barely see through
it
and
but she may lay out a plan for you say
mom i've got four months and i'm gonna
graduate and i'm gonna go do this
um thank you so much but i'm a grown
grown up and i know what i'm doing
and
at that point you write letters you call
her
you say well we're having breakfast and
fix your schedules diane
yeah okay whatever whatever that takes
and tell that knuckleheaded ex-husband
of yours to shut up about the stupid
politics
call his daughter and let her know i
love you and you've got a place to come
home to
right
that fair
yeah
i'm so sorry you found yourself in this
position um
there's just these and this is to all
the parents out there there's these
precipice moments
um maybe i hope this isn't a bad analogy
it might be i'm just thinking off top of
my head as i'm going here um i let my
kids climb trees all the time they're
always climbing trees and falling down
and doing whatever
there's a point though they get too high
up on that branch
are they probably gonna fall no but if
they do they don't come back it's too
high it's too unsafe that that branch is
too flimsy
so i'm all about scratches and bruises
and failing and falling down
i'm about somebody gets in a bad
relationship and it's like
i love you i'ma stand by you
but you're 25 and you're making grown-up
adult choices
um
and then there's a few moments like
addiction
there's a few moments like
um
this when sudden when a a light switch
flips and somebody who was one person
becomes a completely different person
especially in that environment
it's just full of heartache and sadness
and
despair
and wrapped up in celebrations and loud
lights and loud music and beautiful
people it's just a despair
[Music]
that i'm gonna go get my daughter i'm
gonna go get my daughter
and if she doesn't come with me because
i can't force her and at least can she's
gonna know that guy loves me
and that guy was willing to storm the
gates of hell to come get me
i see you
and i still love you anyway
that's what i want my kids to know